[Music]
in virtual nuke news
submitted by extra kimchi me too that's
the first non Asian thing is I know I
don't like sauerkraut I love Sarkar sick
[ __ ] it's not the same kimchi tastes
fishy they got that shrimp or whatever
fish sauce
Western pickles they don't use fish and
seaweed products it has this fishy taste
the fishy taste the better for me to
Japanese students created a virtual
reality sequence of the hiroshima attack
yay that's sad it's sad
so when you're in virtual reality world
you see people crying and screaming and
burning and [ __ ] I don't think people
had a chance to scream do you know I
just get vaporized instantly ha yeah we
know someone their grandparents escaped
the bomb because his grandparents knew
how to read English oh because they were
raised in the US so they went to Japan
to study or whatever we read the leaflet
yeah because the u.s. dropped leaflets
saying we're gonna bomb so evacuate but
it was all in English so people looked
at it like they didn't know what what it
was saying it was propaganda or whatever
but they were like holy [ __ ] we all got
to go so then while they're on the train
like going away they saw the [ __ ]
bomb just well they try to round up as
many people as possible as they were
running but they can't tell the whole
city you know they only had a matter of
like oh no like 10 minutes or some [ __ ]
yes very nice of the United States to
drop belief that even very nice yeah
before they [ __ ] Massacre all those
people right that was an investment do
the invested money to get the grass in
terms of engagement of war at the person
you're writing I wonder if they just
printed it on a piece of paper or they
had like a flyer like with a bomb and
everything or and the timing too was it
like the leaflet and the bomb
like this or was it like the leaflet and
then at least like an hour - no no it
wasn't ten minutes they gave me heads up
it was like I don't know if it was an
hour or whatever I don't know but it was
it was a same day it wasn't like six
minutes later there's enough time for
them to get on a charity I said okay
that's a good amount of time I guess it
was it's up I'll try to keep it
anonymous oh I'm just kidding not even a
secret yeah it's a bit scrappers it's a
buddy Vance a group of a Japanese high
school students for the past two years
have been working on producing a five
minute virtual reality experience I
already create the sights and the sound
- the people of the attack so this is 73
years ago that this happened on August 6
1945 the bombing of Hiroshima killed
140,000 people
days later his second u.s. atomic bomb
killed 70,000 people in Nagas afternoon
that's [ __ ] crazy
and then Japan surrendered six days
after that and ending world war two so
I'm gonna show you guys a video virtual
reality thing that the kids created how
would these kids create this they're so
crazy they actually worked with
survivors to create this and for them I
gosh I know I thought that was kind of
odd cuz they're saying that can you
please tell me about when your hair
burned off what did that look and feel
like I don't know if there were
survivors that actually got hit with it
no well there's no survivors
grandparents are considered survivors
because they survived it but they didn't
go through it because there are people
in that area that was close and got
radiation poisoning and yeah and there
were all these like birth defects yeah
people who saw the blast no implying -
oh yeah so [ __ ] break well maybe they
were far enough because birthday - it's
not that great really five years the
world it's really dark I'm trying to say
like shitty-ass high school work all
high school projects suck the videos all
not to the airbox
oh [ __ ] man damn good and I was like the
end of the world oh my God look at this
how is that a high school project when
people are watching VR looks [ __ ]
hilarious
yeah it's good for a high school project
sure I'm like five years but what's
crazy two years I wish I saved my high
school projects they were so bad
Albert's glue here all over the place
and the [ __ ] few colored dots and
some pasted [ __ ] on it I found my high
school cooking project for my Chinese
class and I tagged the title and it says
Mapo tofu oh it's just I have to cook
like a Chinese dish but then you like it
was my chance to express creativity so I
like I like drew it all out did you buy
the one in the pack we're all you got to
do is warm up and add tofu to make it um
scratch oh I scratched me like like
starting with soy sauce damn you did it
from scratch yeah my high school
multimedia final project thing was me my
friends getting attacked by a bunch of
ninjas and the only way we could beat
them was playing globetrotters music and
playing basketball around the neck you
love ninja [ __ ] even a ninja for like
your Halloween you a book was that
what's that ninja better be a ninja it's
all jokes is that boy you talk about
yeah I gotta give you this other
cartoons when I was a kid like there was
a globe tires cartoon and they would
defeat bad guys but basketball around
them it's so crazy you love binges [ __ ]
but you're just way too big to be a
ninja I know you never like five foot
two or something like that
thanks for your [ __ ] small they're
supposed to be like jockeys by day
ninjas by night yes there's really Hills
mo some [ __ ] Japanese people were just
smaller back dirty small now
yeah yeah but the whole world was yeah
yeah even Napoleon's army yeah they're
tiny children do you know what's crazy
is the people that went through all this
the wars and everything they're like
alive till this day like they're still
here how long we're gonna live in all
this [ __ ] that we're gonna see by the
time we're their age I hope so like
yesterday you escaped this bomb and then
today you're on Facebook and you just
[ __ ] talking to your granny's timing
on your phone dude your kids who were
born on 9/11 who are turning 18 like
next year oh my god yeah dog there's a
lot of [ __ ] happens
Museum Memorial and I was still moving
because I remember that day like I
remember seeing those images that they
had in the museum that day that it
happened and so I was trying really hard
not to cry and then like my eyes got
really watery and Isaac's like mommy are
you okay and I'm like yeah baby how do
you feel about all this I'm like well
it's sad like it's never gonna fully hit
you cuz you're you weren't alive when
that happened like you don't understand
just like how we don't understand like
this stuff's like we don't we do a
Kennedy assassination none of us are
like the Trojan War there's some people
out there yeah there's like what do you
call it survivor's guilt thing like like
but we have that in the periphery we're
like we're just around and we saw the
images and [ __ ] but there's something to
that psychologically that connects us to
the event yeah I remember it was first
period we had [ __ ] PE and we were
just lined it up with TVs and all of us
were just watching and then I was like
it's just buildings on smoke man can we
[ __ ] run or something oh my god
that's how you thought about it yeah you
didn't know what it meant
the my mentality at that age was imma
sell drugs just a couple months ago my
friend got shot at like a meet-up fight
and then like you know you were 18 right
no that's 2001 yeah I was like 16 17 oh
so my mind was already like full of
violence or my world was so something
something like that I'll give a [ __ ] man
I think you're just unique though
because it's a lot like I don't know my
friends weren't affected by either yeah
cuz everyone was like oh [ __ ] are we
going into World War 3 now like this is
[ __ ] war time that's what it felt
like it wasn't like the event was so
clear was more like oh [ __ ] this is like
the stuff that we read about in the
history like we might actually go to war
I remember every time I plane was more
after that keyboard it was crazy
even just being there that day planes
kept flying by and then Isaac like look
he kept looking I'm like oh man that's
crazy
and then we wouldn't see [ __ ] like we'd
be at school and then you just see like
crazy ass like like 35 military choppers
yeah and like skew c-130 aircraft and
[ __ ] like all these four things fly in
our head and just like what the [ __ ] is
going yeah my experience was super scary
cuz this is my second junior in high
school
why don't I was at the military school
some people got a do junior twice okay
that my second junior year in high
school it was at the military school and
we're all in our military uniforms and
the minute that happened they made all
of us change into PE clothes because
like since the country is under attack
they don't know if other bases or other
military schools or anything else is
gonna be under attack and since we're
not part of the military it became it
was really like real to us they wanted
you to be serviced yes it wants to be
civilians and make sure that's
completely clear in case like some
terrorist group came on campus or
whatever and they put us in this big-ass
multi-purpose room they line up all the
TVs and then that's where they're giving
us this speech like America is probably
gonna go to war Dan and you guys are
only 16 or 17 but you guys since you
guys have interest in being a military
school you guys are probably the next
ones to go out if you guys whatever
still was like it was like super real to
all of us other oh [ __ ] Dean I stuck
with me the most that day was when I
went to school and I had this really
close friend at the time and she was
Muslim and she came up to me and she was
like crying if she was telling me like
to me I'm Muslim like you can't tell
anyone like every people were gonna
attack me and then I was just like oh my
god it was that's true cuz Hindu people
got shot just because they wore turbans
and [ __ ] and that was so stupid because
people seek sushi yeah a liquor store
owner guy was like kill just for no
reason all kinds of [ __ ]
down I was like damn do they play it in
every single class till the end of this
yeah yeah whole I remember like every
stylist in college at that time but yeah
you were in college yeah what do they do
they lock down the JC or no um yeah no
one was I mean it's JC you can go home
anytime you uh yeah no one was teaching
anything like everyone was just like in
front of their TV like the whole school
was just in front of their TV a little
campus I don't even go to school that
day because we saw it all happen on TV
that morning my parents were like we're
not going anywhere today
everyone thought we're going to World
War three yeah basically did we're still
at war back yeah Popat
yeah then we're never ending war now
thank God thank God every day I know
they didn't Obama promised that we're
gonna get out everybody does
promises promises I think it did Paul
majority of the tea damn but of Iraq
[Music]